bad news for the wannabe treasure
hunters uncharted Paul has been pushed
back once more I'm Dave and welcome to
your gamespot news update after being
delayed to March 2016 then delayed again
to April 2016 uncharted 4 a thief's end
has been delayed for hopefully the final
time hosting on the PlayStation Blog
president and CEO of sony computer
entertainment america Sean Layden wrote
in an effort to meet the considerable
worldwide demand and to ensure that all
gamers worldwide have the opportunity to
play the game on day one we have chosen
to postpone the launch the game by two
weeks to allow for extra manufacturing
time the new release date is May 10 2016
we know this news might be disappointing
and we are sorry to have to make you
wait a little longer to play naughty
Dog's latest the good news is that the
game is phenomenal we are fully
confident that you'll be worth away and
the team at Naughty Dog is eager as ever
for you to experience Nathan Drake's
final adventure spite the delay fans
will get a chance to try out the game
this weekend during an upcoming open
beta multiplayer stress test so we used
that excited about uncharted or as the
allure of pressure worn off let us know
in the comment section below or you can
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
for all your gaming news stay tuned to
gamespot com